i have the best advice for women in
business get your ass up and work kim
kardashian's dishing out her best
business advice i don't know how you're
going to top that but some people aren't
really feeling it we have different
views sometimes on wednesday kim and her
sisters chloe and courtney along with
their mom kris jenner opened up to
variety about the secret to their
success
success is never easy so you just if you
put in the work you will see results
it's that simple but it was this little
tidbit from kim that has some celebs
fired up i have the best advice for
women in business get your [ __ ] ass
up and work in a since-deleted tweet
megan mccain chimed in pointing out that
the vast majority of hardworking
americans are living paycheck to
paycheck and working multiple jobs
adding quote by far the hardest rung to
move up from in america is poverty i say
this born from extreme privilege
meanwhile jamila jamil doubled down on
all that i think people think i hate the
kardashians i don't hate them pointing
out that the skim's founder grew up in
beverly hills with super successful
parents nobody needs to hear your
thoughts on success work ethic as for
that expression that we all have the
same 24 hours to get stuff done in the
day
jamila doesn't agree writing 99.9 of the
world grew up with a very different 24
hours
and on thursday the ladies of the view
slammed kim's statement too
a leg up is what you need in this world
it helps to be born rich also like she
was i mean she had a wealthy father she
had a mother who was a businessman she's
very pretty
she's pretty
and i i just think that people that are
born on third base shouldn't be talking
about how easy it is to hit a home run
but those closest to kim support her
message it seems like nobody wants to
work these days you have to so true
courtney and chloe echoed her statement
in that same interview you have to
surround yourself with people that want
to work have a good work environment
where everyone loves what they do
because you have one life no toxic work
environments
and show up and do the work if you're
the smartest person in that room you've
got to go to another room like you don't
i want to be around really successful
people because that's going to drive me
to be successful and her longtime
publicist tracy romulus praised kim
after the video went viral writing on
instagram in part quote kim is right it
takes blood sweat and tears to start and
build a successful business and in her
case businesses
tracy explains she wasn't offended by
the comment and that we shouldn't be
either quote set your goals and don't
let anyone tell you that your dreams are
too big or can't be accomplished simply
by working your [ __ ] ass off kim's
latest business advice follows what she
told et in 2018. the mogul says you just
gotta do it
i think my smartest business decision
has been
going for it
and not being like having no fear and
just
even if they failed and even if it
hasn't turned out the way that i wanted
to i've learned so much from it so my
advice would be
go for it
[Music]
you